congratulations by finding this video  you have been selected for the program  please go to time.gov and copy the  coordinated universal time and paste it  into the comments below please do not  provide any other information besides  the coordinated universal time doing so  will lead to immediate termination from  the program the information provided to  you in this broadcast is for you and you  alone do not share this information with  any third party or any other member of  the program further information will be  disseminated in accordance with the  coordinated universal time  thank you you may now move on